And I use my phone while running the rice machine.
So if you're laying down, sitting down,
running your rice machine, can you pick up your phone
and talk to somebody on the phone?
Can you go on the internet and scroll Facebook
while you're doing the rife?
The answer is yes, you can.
You may have some interference at different times
on different frequencies.
You may goof up your phone a little bit
or slow down your connection or something like that,
but no, typically you should not have any problems.
Will your phone interfere with the frequencies
coming out of the rife ball
and interfere with your treatment?
No, not at all.
You can, there's no harm.
In that, it's not going to interfere
with the frequencies coming out of the rife ball.
Further questions that I could think of that tie to this.
Can I use the IMF?
Can I do the rife while I do my PMF?
Yes, yes, you can.
There's a totally different frequencies.
They're not going to overlap,
they're not going to cancel each other out.
You can do that.
Can I do my red light therapy while I do my rife?
Yes, you can.
There's no harm in that.
So we have a person that does the son of,
they have kind of rigged it up
or they bring the ball goes through the door
and goes into their sauna.
Is that going to hurt the machine?
No, no, because I wouldn't bring the machine in the sauna,
but if the bulb is in there, it should be fine.
So that person does the rife while he's in the sauna.
Great.
So you could try to do more than one thing at a time.
That's always wise use of time.
So there shouldn't be any issues with frequencies
of the cell phone.
Certainly, we'll not mess up the frequencies,
the treatment frequencies from the rife.
The only thing with using your phone
with the rife could possibly be your phone
could slow down or you could be groupier or something like that.
But we haven't had that issue.